this is about the person who buys an
iPhone and wants to unlock their own
iPhone you want to make a modification
to run software of your choice to use
the carrier of your choice you should be
able to do that the DMCA this law
intended to protect digital locks that
was to protect DVDs and music and DRM
digital rights management on
entertainment products Congress when
they passed the law they weren't
thinking oh you know we passed this law
because we think hardware manufacturers
should be able to have total control
over everything you ever do a phone that
you buy that wasn't why the law was
passed and that's exactly why we think
an exemption is justified think of this
as why is this any different from my car
right how would we feel if when you
bought a car the car vendor said you
have to use authorized parts you have to
use our authorized dealer repair service
in fact you have to listen only to radio
stations that we approve and you can
only buy gas from gas stations that we
approve right I mean that's basically
what apples sing you can understand why
they want that right the amount of
control that gives them the amount of
ability to control who gets to compete
you want to build an app we basically
have to go ask Apple's permission that's
a great place to be if your Apple right
Apple takes 30% off the top of every app
sold in the store I understand why Apple
should want this device to be locked
down but I see no reason why consumers
and innovators should find that to be
acceptable and I see no reason why
copyright law thinks that that's a good
thing now Apple has not sued anybody for
jailbreaking a phone as far as I know
and in fact Apple hasn't even pursued
the people like the iPhone Dev team that
produced the software that allows you to
jailbreak your phone but the legal doubt
the cloud that is hanging over this
entire area has made it more difficult
for people to open their own app stores
it's made it more difficult for
developers to develop for this community
people probably heard Apple has denied
hundreds and hundreds of apps and for
all kinds of reasons censorship
competition you name it what we've asked
for it would equally apply to Android
phones and any other smartphone that has
a system that's intended to prevent
software from running on the device if
the Copyright Office were to deny our
proposed exemption I think it would be
bad news for the independent competing
ecology of you know apps that are being
developed right I think it's good for
consumers and it's good for innovation
for there to be as many apps and as many
alternate app stores as possible
Apple has often argued well this is
about security and users don't want the
risk of getting an application that
might be bad for them again the point
here is nobody's forcing you to download
apps from anywhere else if you feel like
Apple is the safe place and it gives you
everything you want then no problem go
ahead we're not saying you have to give
that up
we're just saying if there is an app
that you want from a vendor you trust
legitimate app that you want to buy that
should be your business not apples
business if the Copyright Office were to
grant this exemption it would make it
clear that owners of iPhones could
jailbreak their phone they could modify
the phone to use whatever software they
legitimately acquired not just from the
AI the Apple Store but from other stores
on the Internet as well